in this example you can see we have a
leading coefficient of two so what we
want to do is we want to divide
everything by two left and right sides
of the equation so if we do that zero
divided by two is zero here we get one x
squared minus five halves X plus four
now we want to move the four to the
other side just to get it out of the way
so we're going to subtract four from
both sides of the equation if we do that
we get x squared minus five halves x
equals negative four now we want to take
half of this quantity in front of the X
and square it so half of negative five
halves let's just do the work over here
on the side we get negative five fours
and if we square that negative five
squared is 25 and 4 squared is 16
so we're going to add 25 sixteenths to
the left side of the equation 25
sixteenths to the right side of the
equation now the way we've set this up
is this as a perfect square so when we
factor it remember the trick that we
talked about from this last problem you
can just take half of that middle
coefficient so it's going to be X minus
5/4 the quantity squared and then over
here what we're going to do is we're
going to combine these into one fraction
by multiplying the numerator and
denominator here by 16 we get negative
64 over 16 so negative 64 over 16 plus
25 over 16 is how much well let's see
that looks like it's 30
let's see 39 so that comes out to
negative 39 over 16 and then all we have
to do now is just take the square root
of both sides plus or minus remember as
soon as you take the square root both
sides you get the two answers
square root of 16 that works out nice
square root of 39 that doesn't work out
so nice but square root of negative 1 is
I so we're just going to leave this as
square root of 39
I hear the square and the square root
cancel one another out we just get X
minus 5/4 and then what we're going to
do is we're going to add five fourths to
both sides remember to put that 5/4 in
front of the plus or minus okay and so
now these cancel out and you can see you
get x equals 5/4 plus or minus square
root of 39 over four I so I hope this
helped you understand how to solve
equations by completing the square
subscribe to the channel check out some
more math videos on Mario's math tutor
and YouTube channel and I look forward
to helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon